ja ich habe mir gestern die
konstituierende sitzung des 20 deutschen
bundestags angesehen und mir auch die
rede des us präsidenten wolfgang
schäuble angehört die ich insgesamt sehr
gut fand aber es gab noch ein paar
punkte wo man danach sich ein bisschen
gewundert hat denn wolfgang schäuble hat
die parlamentarier insbesondere über
nicht sagen die neuen parlamentarier
daran erinnert dass der bundestag also
ein ort der debatte ist auch der
kontroversen debatte dass man da auch
lernen muss argumente zu akzeptieren die
mich die eigenen sind
[Applaus]
die lustige wollte bei dieser ganzen
geschichte ist die tatsache dass
wolfgang schäuble diese rede nur
deswegen halten konnte weil vier jahre
zuvor die geschäftsordnung des
bundestages dahingehend geändert wurde
dass der alterspräsident nicht mehr die
personen der abgeordnete die abgeordnete
mit dem höchsten lebensalter ist sondern
diejenige mit der längsten erfahrung mit
der linken abgeordneten zeit das war in
dem fall wolfgang schäuble 1972 ins
parlament gekommen anderenfalls wäre es
nämlich 20 17 alexander gauland von der
afg gewesen deswegen hat man die
geschäftsordnung geändert ich bin der
letzte der sich nach irgendwelchen reden
von alexander gauland aber der fairness
halber muss man das einfach festhalten
und wolfgang schäuble war mithin der
profiteur
und man kann sagen dass das bauland
eigentlich weg gecancelt wurde also
derjenige der davon profitiert ermahnt
das parlament dem er selbst fuhr dann
daran dass die kontroversen debatten zu
ertragen sind das ist natürlich schon
wirklich nicht ohne witz und ich fand
auch bemerkenswert dass schäuble in
richtung der deutschen gerichtsbarkeit
gesagt hat also die deutsche
gerichtsbarkeit genannt es ist schon
klar dass damit nicht das amtsgericht
straubing gemeint war sondern das
bundesverfassungsgericht das möge jetzt
dann bitteschön nicht mehr so zusagen an
die grenzen seiner kompetenzen gehen was
ist damit gemeint er meinte damit das
bundesverfassungsgericht wird immer
politischer siehe klimaschutz urteil und
er ermahnt also die deutsche
gerichtsbarkeit das
bundesverfassungsgericht dazu sollte man
aber schon auch wissen dass der
präsident ist verfassungsgerichtes
stefan harwardt ist nicht vor allzu
langer zeit stellvertretender
fraktionsvorsitzender der
unionsfraktion war und von der union
selbst ins bundesverfassungsgericht
gehievt wurde also auch da vielleicht
ist das ein bisschen dem hintersinnigen
humor des wolfgang schäuble zu schreiben
genauso wie die tatsache dass er in
richtung der klimaaktivisten gesagt hat
also man möge doch bitte seine ziele
nicht absolut setzen das gehört sich
nicht also absolutismus klima
absolutismus ist noch keine politik dazu
würde mir auch ein fallen wer ist es
denn wenn die freude jetzt computer
aktivisten hoffähig gemacht hat das war
angela merkel selbst es war angela
merkel selbst indem sie mehrfach kreta
thunberg getroffen und dadurch
nobilitiert hat insofern muss ich schon
sagen die ermahnungen und vorwürfe des
wolfgang schütte fallen doch zum
großteil auf ihn selbst wird zumindest
auf seine eigene partei zurück also da
antworte ich sehr gern hier energie also
zuerst
war ich schon längst zeit dass man die
geschäftsordnung ändert was was das
anbelangt mir geht es da wieder um
bauland oder um schäuble
hat es gestern auch gesprochen worden
wolfgang schäuble hat das absolut
verdient stimmt auch wenn man seit 72 im
parlament ist es keine frage aber ich
denke es ist schon richtig dass und die
geschäftsordnung sollte dann auch so
bleiben dass derjenige der am längsten
im parlament ist auch die aber vorher
mal fragen warum hat man 20 17 geändert
das hat er doch nur den grund dem
bauland zu verhindern war das alles
jetzt das sage ich nicht ich hab ich
habe gesagt für mich ist es nur
folgerichtig dass man das so macht das
die einige der am längsten oder
diejenige die am längsten im bundestag
sitzt die eröffnungsrede hält dass das
war auch okay und was die seine rede an
gelangen und das
bundesverfassungsgericht ja und ich
kenne den vorsitzenden sehr gut ich habe
dann auch in der fraktion natürlich
miterlebt und
das haben wir doch alle in den letzten
jahren miterlebt dass das
bundesverfassungsgericht immer etwas
politischer worden ist auch schon vor
stefan arbeiten muss uns nicht allen
gefallen aber
denke die urteile das ist auch gut so
dass die gerichte unparteiisch sind und
dass wir das
maximal kommentieren können wir müssen
es umsetzen was das jetzt alles gefällt
und anscheinend hat wolfgang schäuble
nicht so gefallen dass sie etwas zu
politisch werden und darum heute das so
durch die blume ja angesprochen hat sie
nicht so deutlich angesprochen und ging
also das eben so macht es ja eher selten
so lange hier ist eben so macht ich habe
das super
ich habe es auch gehört und habe ich hab
ja ja gut
ich habe ja auch nicht jedes urteil
erfreut aber nehme es hin weil das
höchste gerichtsbarkeit ist keine frage
und das nächste was die klimaaktivisten
anbelangt naja wenn die kanzlerin gerät
atombereich empfängt dann empfängt sie
die konsument das muss jetzt wolfgang
schäuble
hat man schon so ein bisschen so ein
meister des widerspruchs also ja er hat
sich ja selbst als absoluter loyalisten
bezeichnet zur kanzlerin aber trotzdem
hat das immer wieder geschafft in
entscheiden oder oder in wirklich
wegweisenden krisen muss man ja sagen
also beispielsweise euro-krise
beispielsweise auch flüchtlingskrise
doch immer wieder auch dann kritik zu
äußern um am ende trotzdem den kurs zu
unterstützen wir erinnern uns an das
lawinen beispiel was er genannt hat 20
15 euro stehe noch ein wüster eine
meinung zu wolfgang schäuble ist
natürlich jetzt ein minenfeld natürlich
wenn man sich als ausländer da
eingestimmt
also ich muss sagen ich habe den
wolfgang schäuble sehr respektiert als
auch als eine art verkörperung des
klassischen erfolgsmodells der cdu diese
nachkriegs cdu deutsches
wirtschaftswunder tc große figur ein
skeptiker toll aber jetzt diese ganze
geschichte die finde ich peinlich für
schäuble findet das himmel traurig dass
man während des spiels die spielregeln
geändert also da bin ich halt ist mit
t-mobile wenn sie während des spiels die
spielregeln aber ändern einfach in
diesen unerwünschten händler und nicht
auf diesen sitz kommen zu lassen was
wirklich schäbig das finde ich auch in
dem sinn kleinkariert gegenüber den
ganzen demokratischen prozessen ich
glaube ein parlament hat auch eine
verpflichtung die spielregeln
aufrechtzuerhalten wenn der staat
während des spiels zum beispiel auch im
fußball weiter ich bin vom
schiedsrichter wegen des fußballspiels
den spielregeln aber ändern wenn es der
stadt macht da muss man sich nicht
wundern wenn er auch die bürger dann
tricks sind und glauben ja ich muss die
regel nicht so genau einhalten und
dieses diese sagt mal heuchlerische
dimension des ganzen das verbot für mich
und das beeinträchtigt ein bisschen das
bild das sehr positive bild das ich von
herrn schäuble ist eine tragische figur
wenn man jetzt mal die letzten 30 40
jahre auch in der bundesrepublikanischen
geschichte revue passieren lässt also
was für ein meisterstück hatte
abgeliefert 1989 90 mit dem
einheitsvertrag das muss man wirklich
sagen dann der dramatische
tiefschlag fast mit dem leben bezahlt
und dann sollte die politische karriere
irgendwann wieder fahrt aufnehmen und
dann fliegen ihm da die schwarzen kassen
um die ohren er kann nicht
bundespräsident wer also kann weder
kanzlerkandidat werden noch
bundespräsident werden er wird dann als
bundestagspräsident muss man auch sagen
scheine nicht freiwillig aus dem amt
sein wird rausgeschmissen weil das
wahlergebnis so desaströs ist wie es ist
er hat auch noch den falschen kandidaten
durchgeboxt also eine eine durchaus
extrem glorreich begonnene karriere
obwohl der einheitsvertrag der woche
auch schon 18 jahren der politik aber
aber am ende doch eigentlich muss man
sagen ziemlich tragisch und überhaupt
weggeholt verbittern und laster ist ja
auch widersprechen für mich zeigt das
beispiel wolfgang schäuble dass man gar
nicht kanzler werden muss oder
bundespräsident war sehr bestimmt wollte
da bin ich beide mit der trage aber für
mich war immer schon von klein auf einer
der großen gründen der deutschen politik
also ich finde wolfgang schäuble weil
auch immer eine institution in
deutschland und wenn er was gesagt hat
man auch das ja aber beispielsweise als
finanzminister acht jahre hat er ja die
kasse gehütet muss man auch sagen hat
wolfgang schäuble nicht dazu beigetragen
dass beispielsweise die steuern sinken
hier hat davon profitiert und das war
sein großes großer erfolg sei die
sogenannte schwarze null über für die er
sicher gerühmt hat wie ist denn die
zustande gekommen die ist nicht
zusteigen kommen bei wolfgang schäuble
knallhart gespart hat die ist zustande
gekommen weil die ezb den zins immer
weiter gesenkt hat immer gab es gar
keine zinsen mehr und wolfgang schäuble
hat sich über dramatische das kind
ersparen aber
selbstverständlich hat er gar nichts
zugesagt es war ein teil der dort nicht
gibt nein wenn die zinsausgaben von 42
milliarden im jahr die plötzlich auf 16
milliarden schrumpfen dann haben sie ein
delta von fast 30 milliarden 30
milliarden von wahnsinn ich habe sechs
jahre im haushaltsausschuss jahr haben
die zahl und kennzahlen auch gut 2014
haben wir begonnen mit dem haushalt von
290 milliarden und vor corinna hätte man
haushalt mit 360 milliarden ohne
steuererhöhungen
es war auch ein grund der
wirtschaftsaufschwung und dadurch die
mehreinnahmen an steuern was sie sagen
ist richtig aber
direkt ins politik die hat natürlich den
den staats- und den länderhaushalten
unglaublich geholfen